جينيفر، هل يمكنك أن تخبرني بما حدث
لك،
نعم، لذلك
كنت سأصطحب ابنتي الصغيرة
من الرقص، ابنتي الكبرى هي
متسابقة تزلج ولم تتسابق منذ
فترة، لذلك كانت في الشمال تتدرب
لسباق  في نهاية الأسبوع
تلقيت مكالمة من
رقم مجهول وفجأة سمعت
صوت ابنتي صوت ابنتي الكبرى
تنتحب وتبكي وتقول أمي
وأم أنا بخير ما حدث معتقدة
أنها تأذيت آه أمي أمي لقد أخطأت و  لقد
رأتني وتبكي، فقلت ماذا
فعلت ماذا حدث ثم
فجأة سمعت صوت هذا الرجل يقول ضع
رأسك للخلف واستلقِ لذا في تلك
اللحظة اعتقدت أنها كانت تُنقل وتم
سحبها من الجبل
حدث شيء ما، ثم أصبحت مثل
أمي، هؤلاء الرجال السيئون يطلبون مني مساعدتي،
ساعدني، ساعدني، هذا يصيبني بالقشعريرة بمجرد
سرد القصة مرة أخرى، لكن هذا الرجل
يتصل على الهاتف ويقول
لي لقد حصلت على ابنتك، هذه هي  كيف ستسير الأمور،
لن
تتصل بالشرطة، لن
تتصل بأي شخص إذا فعلت ذلك، سأقوم بضخها
مليئة بالمخدرات، وسأقضي طريقي
معها على قطارة في المكسيك و  في
الخلفية كانت تبكي وتبكي
وتقول أمي أرجوك ساعديني ساعدني أمي
ساعدني في هذا اليأس،
ثم قرر أن يبدأ في المطالبة
بفدية قدرها مليون دولار
وأه يريد النقود أنا بخير
لا أعرف كيف  سأحصل على مليون
دولار نقدًا أو ما شابه ثم
بدأ يغضب مني اه ثم قال
حسنًا سأأخذ خمسين ألف
دولار فقلت حسنًا اه كيف يمكنني
إرسالها إليك كيف يمكنني تحويلها إليك
في هذه الأثناء، عادت الأم التي اتصلت برقم 9-1-1 إلى
الداخل وكانت تبدو وكأن هناك
عملية احتيال تجري، إنها عملية احتيال تعتمد على الذكاء الاصطناعي، إنهم
يسرقون أصوات الناس
فقط لإعلامك بأنني بخير،
من الجيد معرفة ذلك ولكن  ما زلت بحاجة إلى
معرفة ما إذا كانت ابنتي آمنة
وفي ذلك الوقت تمكنت الأم الأخرى
أخيرًا من الاتصال بزوجي عبر
الهاتف، وتمكن ابني الأكبر من الاتصال بابنتي
بالهاتف
وتمكنا من تحديد موقعها والتأكد من ذلك.
أنها كانت آمنة
ولذا لم أصدق في البداية
أنها كانت آمنة لأن صوتها كان
حقيقيًا جدًا بالنسبة لي في الخلفية عندما
اتصلوا بي لدرجة أنني طلبت
عدة مرات من فضلك التحقق من
أنها هي حقًا لأنني  لم أكن أعرف
ما الذي كان يحدث، وبعد أن
سلموني الهاتف معها، عرفت
أنها آمنة ومن ثم شعرت
بالانزعاج الشديد من الرجال الذين تعرفهم
اتصلوا به بشأن عملية الاحتيال،
واستمروا في الإصرار على أن الأمر ليس كذلك  عملية احتيال
ثم أغلقت المكالمة معهم